more than any other comic book hero
Superman has been as defined by his
portrayals off the page as he is within
them whether it's the radio show
introducing Kryptonite and Jimmy Olsen
in the 40s or the way Christopher Reeve
made audiences believe a man could fly
in 1978 the men playing the Man of Steel
have shaped how the world views Superman
but which one did it best here's a look
at every live-action version of Superman
ranked from worst to best Superman
Returns 2006's Superman Returns isn't
just terrible it's the kind of terrible
that makes you wonder how it happened
it's mystifying on every level starting
with the fact that it's meant to be a
sequel to the director's cut of Superman
- not the theatrical release but Richard
Donner's original version which had only
been released on DVD a few years earlier
that's weird
especially considering it ignores the
two sequels to Superman - that already
existed worse though the version of
Superman that the movie presents us is
remarkably unappealing after leaving
Earth for five years to check and see if
Krypton was still blown up Superman
returns to find that Lois Lane has been
spending the intervening years raising
their five-year-old child Superman then
mopes around basically stalking his
ex-girlfriend for two hours the most
frustrating part about the whole thing
is that Brandon Ralph is actually good
in the role he's got a great look he
comes off as genuine and heroic and he's
incredibly likable he just happens to be
playing a version of Superman that's
none of these things it's a bird it's a
plane it's Superman everywhere but we
could get together this 1975 TV
adaptation of the popular 60s Broadway
musical taps ended the same campy vibe
that made the Batman TV show such a big
hit that actually led to some pretty
cool stuff - the sets being drawn is
flat comic-book style backgrounds for
the actors to play against complete with
panel borders drawn in was a great idea
and there are a few really well-done
gags plus you've got possibilities the
song in which of vampy femme fatale
swings a meet Clark Kent around the room
while undressing him is something else
in practice though it just doesn't come
together thanks in large part to david
wilson's
Superman like almost everyone else in
the cast he feels like he's constantly
winking at the audience about how goofy
this entire thing is he plays Clark Kent
just a little too weedy and bored and a
super man is a little too much of a
blowhard to ever really want to see him
win Superboy
before Smallville managed to carve out a
solid decade on the airwaves the story
of a younger pre-super man Clark Kent
found its way into syndicated television
as Superboy in 1988 set during Clark's
college years in Florida the first
season was shot on a tight budget but
still managed to tell pretty interesting
stories about its title character played
by John Haynes Newton though the series
was a hit
Newton lasted only a single season after
producers used a DUI as an excuse to
replace him after he asked for a pay
raise this imposter will be more than
happy to sign a full confession to the
crimes committed in my name Superman
here's the weirdest thing about kirk
allen's tenure as superman in the 1948
serial while his name did appear on the
posters identifying him as the actor who
played Clark Kent
Columbia Pictures never actually credit
him in the serial itself instead they
promoted the film as starring Superman
taking some time off from fighting crime
and saving the world to make his motion
picture debut looking back it seems like
a pretty bizarre promotional choice but
in all honesty Allen really did sell it
his big smile and hellraiser attitude
were a great match for the early
iteration of the character
there was only one truly bizarre thing
about the serial version of Superman
though since they didn't have the budget
for a live-action special effect all the
scenes of Superman flying were done by
showing Alan's very human form quickly
turning into an animated cartoon that
would fly around before landing behind
something so they wouldn't have to
animate the landing that's weird
Superman dull New York is Turkey's 1979
bootleg action ethic the return of
Superman good no no it is not
is it however absolutely worth watching
only to see how truly insane it is yes
since Turkish laws at the time prevented
American blockbusters like Superman from
being shown enterprising Turkish
filmmakers just made
version this resulted in a film in which
a suspiciously scrawny Superman comes to
earth from a Krypton that appears to be
decorated by Christmas tree ornaments
and the shots of Superman flying are
done by dangling a Ken doll and a
homemade Superman costume on a string so
no it's not what you'd call good but
tape and Aamir's performance is
certainly unique and incredibly
entertaining The Adventures of Superboy
after John Newton left the Superboy
television show the title for the second
third and fourth seasons passed to
Gerard Christopher who benefited from
joining a show that was already a
success as a result he had a lot more to
do than his predecessor both on and off
Spurr christopher actually ended up
writing two episodes of the series
himself he also had the benefit of being
a little older and having a little more
experience despite the fact that he was
playing a sophomore in college
Christopher turned 30 the year he landed
the role and the experience he brought
to the table shows there's a sincerity
to his portrayal of Superboy and as
Clark Kent was purposefully a little
nerdier than Newtons to bring him closer
into step with Christopher Reeves
bumbling stuttering Clark from the films
Smallville with 218 episodes over the
course of ten seasons beginning in 2001
Smallville's Tom Welling put more time
into playing Clark Kent than any other
live-action performer but then that's
also the problem Smallville famously had
an approach rooted in the simple rule no
tights no flights the idea was that
their focus would be on a young Clark
Kent in the years before he decided to
become Superman the show was such a hit
though that it took a whole decade to
get around to becoming Superman as a
result Smallville's Clark becomes a
victim of his own success forced by the
rules of the show into an indecisiveness
that even Hamlet would find a little
annoying the show went on long enough
that it even outlasted the original
setting of the title and Clark ended up
doing pretty much everything you'd
expect to see a grown up Superman do the
thing is he only did it as the red-blue
blur if we ever get around to ranking
red-blue blur
he'll be at the top of the list but as
Superman he leaves a little to be
desired
Lois and Clark the New Adventures of
Superman
Smallville erred on the side of putting
too much
focus on Clark Kent and the DC
blockbusters went to the other extreme
and barely bothered to include
Superman's alter ego at all but
beginning in 1993 Lois and Clark struck
a balance that few other portrayals of
the character have managed to even come
close to the trick is right there in the
title Lois & Clark comes first
emphasizing the love story and this
didn't detract from the action instead
it did the opposite adding a level of
drama that got fans invested in a kind
of ongoing soap opera without ever
letting it get in the way of
super-powered action the single best
thing that Lois and Clark ever did was
after three different fake outz calling
the episode where the title characters
got married swear to god this time we're
not kidding that said a close second was
the way that Dean Cain's taken the Man
of Steel got the dynamic of the secret
identity right Superman is what he does
Clark Kent is who he is that's
ridiculous you are Superman no Lois
Superman is what I can do
Clark is Who I am and a close third
[Music]
Man of Steel and the DC extended
universe the DCE you may have its
origins in an unrelentingly bleak place
but Henry Cavill Zarqa Superman
transcends even the dreariest parts as
Superman he's pretty much the truest
thing you'll ever get to his comic
appearance and for the first time on
screen he's not just a dude with
superpowers but an alien god sure his
initial art consists of murdering the
villain getting his butt whooped by
Batman and then dying pretty dark but
also a great match for Ben Affleck's
Batman by the end of 2017 s Justice
League we've got a sunnier and more
optimistic version of Superman a guy who
could joke around with the flash and
hopefully open the door to a much
brighter DC EU what more could you want
in a Superman The Adventures of Superman
even though the show was on the air for
over a hundred episodes beginning in
1952
the most defining moment of George
Reeves tenure as Superman on The
Adventures of Superman didn't happen on
the screen it happened in real life
Reeves was acutely aware of the fact
that kids looked up to him he even quit
smoking so that he wouldn't be caught by
a photographer and set a bad example for
his younger viewers and pushed for
scripts that would give good messages
about respect and tolerance of others
the downside to that was that when he
made public appearances in costume a few
children would attempt to test
Superman's invulnerability with a quick
punch or kick to the shins at one
appearance a kid took things much
further by bringing his father's pistol
in an effort to see if bullets would
really bounce off Superman Reeves
thinking quickly convinced the child to
hand over the loaded gun as immortalized
in the 2006 film Hollywood Land if you
did shoot me
and the bullet bounced off it might
accidentally hit someone else we don't
want that to happen new it that's the
kind of thing Superman himself would
have done Supergirl
there's a moment in the second season of
Supergirl where everyone is eagerly
awaiting the arrival of Kara zor-el more
famous cousin when he does show up
Superman lands and then spends the next
few minutes smiling and shaking hands
with everyone learning their names and
greeting them not as an alien Savior but
as someone who sees them as equals
that's the moment where it was clear
that the show's producers understood
Superman as well as they understand his
cousin Tyler hoechlin take on Superman
has a warmth and honesty that goes
perfectly with the world the show has
created an affable attitude and humanity
that doesn't go away when he takes off
his glasses with his first appearance in
2017 he might not have the tenure of
some of the other supermen on this list
but what he does have is a note perfect
vision of a hero who's here to help
Superman if you go looking for people's
thoughts about Christopher Reeves
performance as the Man of Steel starting
in 1978 Superman the one thing you'll
read over and over is that he looked
like he stepped off the pages of the
comics and into the real world but the
truth is that Reeve embodied the idea of
Superman so well that the comics had the
change to keep up his easy smile his
reassuring confidence it's all there on
screen he even made the eye-popping
costume look great and did such a great
job with the double identity that it was
easy to believe the citizens of
Metropolis would overlook the meek
slouchy Clark Kent as a disguise for
Superman looking back at them years
later the movies themselves can be
wildly uneven 3 & 4 aren't as bad as you
remember and the first who aren't as
good but at least Reeves performance
remains unassailably great in virtually
every way thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]